I said I wanna try better care to
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to this video so I'm here with
the one and only smile - Subhan Allah
subscribe that was general resistance of
you guys've inshallah now we're reacting
to t-pain how he went from 40 million
pounds to zero
Wow interesting who is t-pain why has he
got tea is he still in pain the jokes
and the bus
anyways so basically he paint is a music
artist hip-hop R&B wrap up you wanna
call it we're gonna call it yeah yeah
very popular yeah it was actually
waivable at one point so I used to his
music a lot and he was someone that
would like even ever anyone that knows
that listed music which is actually
harder more useless to music yeah you
will know that it has a massive impact
on your brain yeah a massive massive
impact and it can be very dangerous as
well and some people that listen to
certain kind of music they live their
lifestyle couldn't endure so glue music
plays a massive role up units I believe
in crime gun crime life crime
it's a massive some people say it's odd
corny or cool whoever you like when
people are talking about shooting
dropping I shot that person this day you
know and yeah an effect yeah yeah okay
and the music that you listen to can
affect you and these kinds of traps that
they had they even had one of a con yeah
yeah I don't find it yeah which was
based on love do you get it I remember
listening to it and you know you know it
just gets you in that you know mood etc
even if you don't in love it's like you
just want to be in love yeah you get
it's all you can see how it promotes her
own relationships will come time I Myers
documentary we talk about suspect the
music side of it how it affects your
brain so the music documentary if people
are gonna ask when is it coming out when
Charlotte sued shall assume with we
finished but I did a few other its
refining it yeah yeah we need to in
detail it's good it's gonna be well
finish Walla so this up to the chase
there's the video okay it's very
interesting yeah okay
I run came across this by the way
expense that you ever bought the biggest
thing that you spent besides the house
um that was just to left now Bugatti
a favor now straight up
one point two and you spent 1.2 million
of yeah and got rid of it a week later
not a week later I had it right five
months and why'd you benefit they said
you need to break something I broke it I
put a hole in the radiator driftin no I
just found out you can't do that now so
you know it was a very take note you can
do it you can drift but if you put a
hole in one of the four radiators they
have to replace all the radiators and
they lord have mercy
that's not a grin I didn't want to do
that they decided to let it go
yeah because at that point that's when I
was running out of money you know I'm
saying and that's when my accountant was
like dude you just got it you're out of
money and I was like no I'm not I got
this house I wanna get I got this other
house for my assistance and you know
runners and my producers and stuff so we
bought a house out there and we just
start going crazy with the money I
wouldn't pay attention to it as you know
I thought if I didn't have access to
Morrow in the counseling I wouldn't have
to look at it so you know I'm saying it
was you see here no only we as the
viewers people that buy his music idea
that's me we yeah is that not only do we
do that and we live in a virtual reality
and like what we perceive Yeah right but
you can see what this lifestyle he was
living in this virtual reality way for
the money's not gonna run out are you
talking about mask or 14 million are you
mad yeah what's what does the word
one-out mean what's the definition about
cuz that's not that's not right now
so not only wearing delusion he himself
is in the delusion that you know it's
gonna last forever you know I'm saying
it was bad business choices Wow yeah I
mean as soon as I drove it off the lot
1.2 mil so was it bad and loses 400
grand Matt throw it off the lot they
probably went today he bought a brand
new sword yeah no no I'll put the hole
in the ready
this is driving at fans everywhere when
you say you was broke you got like zero
dollars broke I like had to borrow money
to get my kids Burger King Wow imagine
imagine you thinking
t-pain broke that he's gonna look
imagine you looking at this desk people
hear you when we see when people see me
or you
what are public figures yeah people have
the perception about me but when I talk
people are do do but people know about
it
people don't people have this perception
like boiling that we're kicking in duty
I'm trying to see and they have a level
of respect for you so imagine these
rappers who are like international yeah
I imagine you imagine you take my
picture t-bone Rob I just met you baby
take a picture and then imagine you come
to assist you you know ain't enough
money to buy booking for my kids bro
money to buy anything for your kids you
would never in a million years think a
rapper like that who's selling records
in the millions would buy Burger King's
will ever be in that situation
okay and by baking know I'm seeing to
buy but be in that situation
nah I mean what see it goes back to how
he began cuz it's other and your risk is
written and it just shows you like you
know do um transy and the thing with
rappers is is like he keeps mentioning
the fact that he's not very smart
there's a few things that rappers need
to do number one you own your masters
yeah and number two you can never rely
just on your music and if you see the
the most successful of the hip-hop
artist dr. Dre PDD even Akon he's done
some good charity work he has but if 50
cent all three of these guys they're in
the top 10 only because they have shares
in businesses by 50 cents got shown
and vitaminwater vitamin water wada P
Diddy's got shares in syrup and tree
beats so again it comes down to being
educated because at the end of the day
the people that are making the most
money in the music industry are the
business people behind the scenes so
again like you said it's it's like a
game of deception yes like the people
that are pulling the strings are making
the money yes but the people being
pulled they're not making as much money
exactly exactly and this is a reality
because he himself fell into that trap
where he's going to bind a bratty 1.2
mil that's not smart business decision
you don't see you don't see Bill Gates
and Mark Zuckerberg going around in this
one Chauncey they need they get you
hooked up in this lifestyle and these
it's basically deception which I don't
come to the Quran IOH a few minutes this
is watching Wow ya have to have it
what's the most you've had in the bank I
want
40 million Jesus Christ how do you have
a headline 40 billion dollars to zero
yeah it'll get all bad spending no bad
investment it was a lot of bad
investments a lot of things vested that
didn't work for 40 min hours what were
you invested in real estate real estate
yeah you buy retail no but I was letting
my manager do it he was way more
optimistic than I was
so what do you mean optimistic you would
just buy complete dumps and think that
we can just paint and then never sold
anything that we bought even now like
none of those areas y'all bought in
became go we had to let him go I mean we
do we just have to let everything go you
know is there anything of you to held
onto would be work for a lot now no not
at all these terrible neighborhoods but
it was like no check on it every now and
then it's like crap not sure now you can
see here before you talk about that that
the last point that he mentioned was he
trusted his manager and just kind of let
him do what he was doing you got to be
smart yourself yes and you can never
rely on other people because I mean when
it comes to money they there's a
potential of them screwing you over
yeah and in surah al-anam what someone
says why why then did they not
supplicate in humidity when a calamity
came upon them instead their hearts were
hardened and and Satan adorned for them
what they were doing and this happened
to a lot of things yeah a lot of things
bro we tend to compare our left others
we're always looking at others and we
know the recent controversies that
happen with a certain couple yeah oh my
gosh you know we this is people make it
work any much people make it to other I
wish my mind's eye that I wouldn't be
nothin less Dean's the repentance that
can imagine why it was based on
perception again you know certain things
that don't you yeah and be it that for
example you're a married man
etc you're looking elsewhere you always
compare shaytans always gonna add on
other things
make it beauty to cross the other side
it seems like that
and then almost melted something very
profound in verse 44 yeah I said
thereafter when they forgot the advice
the warning from allah subhanaw taala
they were given back sorry thereafter
when they forgot the advice they were
given we open for them doors of
everything so Allah saying we sent
reminder and remind and remind that
remind that tell them look turn back
turn back turn back when they didn't
when they were not taking heed I was
saying we opened the doors for them so
look whatever you want yeah you know
some people that's why we what do we
define the success look at Pharaoh we
own everything people man you know you
judging him you're looking at and Allah
saying here he's opened the doors for
everything what you wanted he was
chasing allah was sending you signs you
don't listen you're stubborn
no i want this and one like that
sometimes no I want this you think you
know what's good for you
and what goes back to tawheed again
you're not trusting are not having
talkin you think you know what's between
yeah I know what does Allah say never so
that when they became proud of what they
were given given they were given I'll
gave it to them yet because they were
asking for it we seized them suddenly
and they they were left in this bed so
imagine you're reaching your pinnacle
and you're thinking arrogantly like it's
me unless any we gave it and if you see
me I did this yeah I did this and I
loved was we seized them and they were
left in this path all of a sudden at
your peak boom this can mean anything is
complete at that bro it can mean that a
lot like t-pain took everything from him
it can be that Allah takes your life
away from you so it just teaches you and
it teaches me that for example bro like
looking after these people etc seemed
like t-pain I would have no affinity
pains in that situation was about Burger
King but I'm in a message I'm in a
better situation than him so I'm saying
that's my man it's just just a reality
check for us to understand and take
Shaitaan as our enemy now alhamdulillah
hit the nail on the spot I mean there's
various actors in their careers that's
what they've said
I think Chandler from friends he was
saying when he was filming loads of
episodes he was he was intoxicated he
was drugged up but people didn't know
that watching that they were being
entertained by him but they didn't know
what was going on behind the scenes they
call it the a game of smoke and mirrors
yeah you you have the lights you've got
certain backgrounds you
certain sets and and people are made to
believe that you are living a certain
way these rappers they rent chains they
rent cars and they give you a certain
impression they rent girls four hundred
pounds a day and then those girls go
those chains go and they're back to
their 95
exactly and another thing that I discuss
in my mind affirmation which is crucial
because we want to prevent divorces is a
lot of Muslim couples portraying a
lifestyle of marriage that is not true
they're putting this persona up there
their best moments yeah these are the
best moments but you know marriage is
not like that you know marriage don't
work like that you know you guys are
each other's face screaming police
throwing chairs madness and I've been
thrown bullets before
no no brother I'm saying marriage is
like that it's sacrifices bro we've
turned marriage into something it's not
and that's why there's an epidemic
levels of divorces left right center
with disgust on it was a pleasure thanks
for coming why is my hand called a news
hope because you're as cold as ice bless
you shala hope you guys learn a lesson
from this do not fall for the light
because it's nothing but smoke and
mirrors and I'm about to smash the
mirrors and a smoke smashed cause my
smoke anyways I'm worried
welcome silly